6 25 in your monday morning got a viewer
complaint from somebody who would know
about dangerous drivers around school
buses viewer brian writes he is a school
bus driver and he sets the stage for us
says on las vegas boulevard and saint
rose parkway in those two left turn
lanes to go west on st rose from las
vegas boulevard he says cars on that
inside turn lane are cutting off school
buses and other cars by jumping into the
lane that gets you onto the northbound
i-15 he says because of this there have
been several school bus crashes at the
intersection and he concludes i think we
need some traffic enforcement in the
area
good idea brian i'll pass your email
along to the nevada highway patrol but
here's a great opportunity to remind all
of us that even if a bus is empty coming
out of the yard near there it's on its
way to carry our most precious cargo
young people on their way to or from
school so if you're going to be a jerky
driver can you at least leave school
buses out of your dangerous behavior
thank you buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone if there is
something driving you crazy email me i'm
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com